New York has always been drawn to that
dynamic point guard for a kid like
Isaiah he has stamped his own signature
move
Gio everybody in the city they like
somebody who's positive put your boy
once we starting apartment everybody
just wanted to be alone with us jelly
Kennedy's took the world by storm
today's a new day got them up in the
suitcase they'll go up town to Harlem
tell him that essentia it's the dawn of
a new age for new york city playground
basketball revitalized by a point guard
from Harlem Isaiah Washington the future
Minnesota gopher is the leader of a
movement known as the jelly fan named
after Isaiah's signature finger roll
move the jelly
the jelly is a finger roll but you know
you just got to add your own little
spice to it
I made jelly my old signature move
because I saw Michael Jordan do the open
legs done and I was younger dumb so I
just had that jelly and just open my leg
it's a lot of jelly moss and I could do
we first accused the glass I won't use
the glass
it went from jelly - jelly pan I'm
starting with the two of us me and Josh
and then we just decided to expand more
people so we could go global next thing
you know we had it paid in my place
Leon's in Washington and we gotta say
Wilson Siobhan Connelly the Jordan
Walker and then we add Emily Sheree
and from there you know or most of us
are like top players in that town around
the country and everybody's want to be
like that basically we just all came
together like brothers and simply be an
only girl we just fired the basketball
world from younger kids Isaiah
Washington
yeah my best friend he told me that I
was investor on New York City he go I
should be recognized just as they were
deli frame grew because of social media
and a lot of people sharing on Facebook
Twitter things like that really to be
honest we just expanded it because those
Guinness girls anytime there's an
announcement that he is going to play at
a certain venue that the park is almost
over right almost like the old school
Rucker games kids are hanging on the
fence as it had a profound impact on
summer basketball mainly because he has
swag to his game and the great part
about him is that he backs it up but
when that such day I'm like [ __ ] shot
short
from tail less funny to you
she next white hair Isaiah and the jelly
plan movement has definitely
re-energized New York City basketball
not only in the playground but just on
the high school season itself the last
time I saw a kid have this impact on
other kids I have to say penny Anderson
at Archbishop Molloy just the bodies
that he created in New York City and
nationally my coach he always told me
you're going to be doing marketing when
you get to college I just hit down
laughs but I think about it like I could
really have a good skill at